the tampa bay rays here this afternoon
and a big start is right-hander luis
patino making his sixth of the season
the record one and two with an era of
5.26 and 25 and two-thirds innings of
work it'll be interesting to watch him
early on to see if there's any kind of
jitters you know you're trying to avoid
the sweep you're going up against a
division rival who just got better
they're in the news an awful lot and so
patino you'd like to see him settle down
making quality pitches early and then
you feel good about things moving
forward strike three called over the
inside corner and that was a pretty good
good morning good afternoon and good
night mr le mayhew from coutinho for out
number one here in the top of the first
the judge moves on to second on the wild
pitch here is giancarlo breaking ball
swinging and missed elevated the slider
and stan swung through it that'll do it
for new york
here in the top of the first they gonna
hit that set making his 21st start
putting together another good season
10-5 2.74
166 strikeouts in 125 innings well
you've heard it before i mean what else
can you say michael he's really good i
mean he's the ace of this yankee staff
so we'll just move on cole ready to go
to work on the first pitch to brandon
lau is lifted in the air down the right
field line fair or foul
it is a fair ball and it's gone
brandon loud jumping all over that first
pitch yankees don't think so they don't
think that was fair dwayne yeah this is
going to be pretty interesting here the
first bates umpire called it a home run
and now coming out of that conference
the ray's not going to be real happy no
first two batters reach against garrett
cole here in the bottom of the first
well you get a chance early against cole
and his pitchers are not going where he
wants him to go swinging a ground ball
back up toward the middle and it's
through for a base in here comes lau
around third up with it floreal he will
have no play he does give the raise a
one nothing lead on the base hit by andy
diaz yeah with rbi number 35 and now
let's see if austin meadows can keep the
line moving there's a swing and a drive
the deep right back out of this judge to
the wall it's gone
boston meadows with a three-run home run
and the race with four in the first
against garrett cole leading four
nothing
can we talk about troy having good
career numbers against garrett cole but
meadows that's his third home run career
against coal remember he had the big one
in game five for the division series and
with two down here is a stubborn florio
he is five for eighteen a homer two rbs
swung on and lifted to left center
kiermeier got a great break down the run
makes the catch to retire the side
glorial gave it a decent ride but kk
off and running and
tracked it down we go to the bottom of
the second inning here's the catcher
mike zunino ground ball and backhanded
by audeur the long throw he gets genino
so the yankees were shifting for zunino
and odor makes the play really nice play
and the shift helps
on that one
if the defense is more normal that
shoots into left center
it was hit very hard and tampa bay as a
runner at second but here's a rose arena
he pops it up cole coming down off the
mound and that ball
is stuck up there apparently
catwalk special it's up there somewhere
what a place
and higgy didn't see it garrett cole for
a minute looked like he saw it the next
thing you know where to go it's got to
come down soon well here comes the one
one-two to a rosarina strike him out on
a slider
six strikeouts for cole no runs
one hit and that will bring dj mayhew to
the plate with a man of war swings and
lines when the right but right there is
phillips who goes to a knee to make the
catch
to retire the side we had a man there
as he picked on the first pitch but
phillips was in the
proper positioning and made the grab
this labor tour as the raise will get
their pet up it looks like jeffrey
springs is going to be the first man to
grab a ball slider driven in the air
left center a rosarina going back at the
track to the wall makes the catch as
torres gave it a ride but rosarina was
able to run it down no bases loaded and
one man out and that'll bring up kevin
carmine swing in a fly ball deep to left
field dinder going back to the wall
and he bobbles in and it's off the wall
he can't make the catch
meadow scores here's a rosarito he will
score on the wall ball single by kevin
kiermeier and it's six nothing rays
that's a catch that he has to make i
mean this is gonna be a deep sacrifice
flight so the rays score a couple of
runs and they chase garrett cole and
that loads the bases with two out and
here is left-handed brett
[Applause]
phillips has just hit a grand slam
it's 10 and nothing raised over the
yankees
phillips with the grand slam
and the raise with double digits
baseball fun today we're turning that
frown upside down aren't we nobody's
getting their there down after just a
couple of tough losses and that also
closes the ledger on call he gives up
eight runs the inning will continue as
jim choi becomes the ninth man to come
to the place
way back off the bat of joy and that
baby is gone
g-man troy with his seventh homewood of
the season it's a two-run shot it's a
12-nothing raised lead here in the sixth
so with
it's been walk home run walk home run
and down in field head boston meadows
two for three on the day swinging a
drive
dude right field again and austin
meadows has just left the yard
a two-run shot on the 2-2 pitch his
second home run of the day number 20 on
the year and the rays tack on two more
it's 14 to nothing
another fastball thrown right into the
swing austin meadows i'll tell you it
has been either well off the plate or
right down the middle
for abreu right sheriff
comes on and for ryan again
it's a matter of just coming out here
and it's easier said than done but
throwing strikes but not too good of
strikes on one so far this year with a
nine era in six games four two thirds
innings five runs swinging he lifted in
the air towards left playable for a
rosarena back to his left now settles
under it and makes the catch and sheriff
gets the man he needed to get here in
the eighth and i have a pretty good
feeling we'll see him back out there
for the nine yankees down to their final
out as sheriff ready with a 2-2 pitch to
wade swing and he popped him up in the
shallow center franco going out
kiermaier coming in franco says he's got
it and he does in the rays win
ray's win ray's win
and they do so emphatically
as they
beat up on the new york yankees today
the final score
thanks to a 10-run sixth inning
the raise
14
and new york
nothing